this is a production of Cornell
University hey good afternoon everyone
so I'll get straight into it so here in
in the central region of New York we
have grape vines that are cultivated
around the Finger Lakes and this is
because of some special characteristics
of the area and you can see here in in
this map that you're seeing this is the
USDA hardiness zone map and you can see
in green where where the area with them
with a milder climate extends from the
Great Lakes
further south because of because of the
Finger Lakes so it is because of these
characteristics that we are able to
cultivate grapevines of the vanilla kind
around here and you can see that if you
look at the map of where we have
wineries in the state of New York you
see that they are located where those
green areas in the map to the left is so
there's climate characteristics that are
that become milder because of these
large bodies of water that we see here
in the in the in the western part of New
York and but still there's some years
where the temperatures drop there are
too low so we we are studying cold
hardiness and grapes to try to
understand what are the characteristics
and the wild grapevines that make them
survive even further north from here and
that the cultivated grapevines are not
that they don't have so here it's just
to show you there's there's different
characteristics for each of the Finger
Lakes so it's a combination of the
geography and the the depth of the lakes
and the the surface area of them that
prevents them from in most winters from
freezing and because of that they have a
they buffer the especially the low
temperatures in the area and then you
might tell me but global warming
we're increasing the temperatures why is
your study relevant why do we need to
understand cold hardiness if we're not
gonna need it in the near future and
then I'll tell you here in these maps we
sees as the winter temperatures are
increasing and even the extremes in
temperature are going up and this is
basically based on that the low
temperatures are rising it's not the the
highs but the low temperatures and the
reason why it's still relevant is
because of this type of phenomenon that
still is going to occur the polar
vortexes that we've been seeing with
greater frequency it's not just because
we came up with a name for them but they
actually have increased in frequency
lately because as the as the air warms
in the southern regions it decreases the
strength of that that Jetstream and
because of that it's able to move
further south and then the the arctic
air moves further south so we're we're
still going to see low extremes in
temperature even though the winter
temperatures are milder and hopefully by
the end of this presentation you'll able
to make your own conclusions and how
because of how grapevines are perceiving
temperatures they might still be
affected by by these events so because
of the the seminar was titled grapevine
survival winter Survival Guide I decided
to talk about fight-or-flight responses
and the grapevines
and so this is the the sort of thing
like a general grapevine that you have
in the late summer with the fruit the
first thing that leaves the grapevine
are the fruit that we're picking and
then as it as the the days become
shorter and the quality of light changes
you start getting the dormancy
established so you get into fall and
once those so those leaves are in the
flight response so they're going to get
away but part of that plant is still
going to be there so
have all the doorman structures that
have to resist the winter temperatures
so I'm gonna talk about especially the
today what I'm going to talk about is
how the the buds of the plants are going
to survive the winter and how they
respond to temperature some of the
things that I'll be talking about end or
dormancy what is in the dormancy if you
cut a bud off of a plant and you try to
grow it very early in the winter when it
hasn't seen or felt any cold it's
basically not going to grow you can see
here this cutting it grows roots but
it's not developing that bud so you're
not seeing bud break in here it's not
growing
whereas when they're in equal doormen
you actually see the you see the the
buds start to grow very quickly and if
you compare the sizes of the roots
you'll see that the this started growing
much earlier than the roots and so the
transition from this end or dormant
state which is a non responsive state
into an eco dormant state where if you
give enough temperatures they'll start
growing it is understood as being a
response to chill accumulation so the
plants have a clock in which they're
counting how many hours they're spanning
in low temperatures typically calculated
between zero and eleven Celsius
somewhere in that range depending on
what what model you're using and so if
we look at the at the map for chilling
accumulation here in the US you'll see
that if you go further north you have
more chilling compared to the south but
if you look at at the Midwest region
you'll see that it actually has less
chilling or it's comparable to the
southern regions that's because they
spend so much time in the below freezing
temperatures during midwinter that they
really don't accumulate chilling so the
plants don't count that into their clock
so you have that in mid to high
latitudes that's really where you have
most of your chill accumulation and then
if you go
further north you don't you don't see
that anymore so here just so you can see
some data and it depends on the year
also that you're looking at so this is a
warm year and you see that here in New
York and Missouri you're going to 1600
hours and in South Dakota you only get a
thousand whereas if we have a very very
cold winter like 2013 2014 we actually
have less chilly accumulated and here in
the New York Region much closer to a
South Dakota gets so it really
fluctuates the responses of the plants
fluctuate from winter to winter I'll
also be talking a lot about differential
thermal analysis or LTE's or the term
that you're gonna hear me say this is
the analysis that we do to evaluate the
cold hardiness of these buds so we cut
them off of the plant we cut them off of
the plant and we're careful to leave
some of the bud cushon because this is
important for them to still have this
phenotype that we're measuring we put
them in these thermoelectric modules
that are that measure changes in voltage
based on on Heat and so we have these
large plates and we put them in a
programmable freezer which is going to
lower the temperature until minus 40
Celsius
and then we get the this record and here
the axis for temperature is flipped so
the the more negative temperatures are
to the right and you'll see that we see
a high temperature exotherm or hg which
is non lethal and then we have a low
temperature exotherm which is where the
buds are being killed by the temperature
and here you see five Peaks from five
different buds and so we we were able to
record the temperatures where these buds
are killed this is based on a super
cooling ability that the buds have
inside of them so the water is actually
able to drop below it's freezing point
without without forming ice crystals
and for for you to understand what this
processes I make this videos every
single winter I have a ton of them to
show what this looks like if you just
look at water so you'll see that that
water is liquid but once you once you
shake it it actually crystallizes so
that water was super cool and then once
once I shook it it was actually able to
form the ice crystals it doesn't
completely freeze because there's as
it's freezing there's heat being
released so it's only partially becoming
solid so we measure this throughout the
winter and you'll see that this curve
has a generally sorry I'm trying to get
rid of that green line that was there I
camp so I'll just keep going so you see
that this a has a generally general
u-shape that follows the air temperature
which is in black so in the bottom you
see the cold hardiness for copper
nestled beyond and Riesling and so we
have what we think about as three phases
so you have an acclamation phase in
which the buds are gaining hardiness
early in the winter you have a
maintenance phase in midwinter where
they're not varying that much and then
in the spring they start losing their
hardiness so they are d acclimating and
you'll see here that there's one point
where the where the air temperature
actually goes below what the cold
hardiness is for those buds actually
there's two points where it gets very
close and what we see when we take those
buds from the field is that we actually
see damage in them so the the but
anatomy and vanilla is that you have
within a bud it's a compound but so you
have three smaller buds and the primary
is the one that has the flower so that's
the one that's going to give you the the
grapes and when we see when we see that
peak exotherm or
we see the temperature dropping below
where the cold hardiness list we see
this damage here where you there's a
browning in the primary bud where is the
secondary and tertiary are still green
in this case so they are able to the
plant will still be able to grow after
this damage but it won't have flowers or
great from this but at least when we
look at two separate winters we see that
they vary across winters and how they
gain hardiness and how they lose
hardness but there's about a constant in
the maximum hardiness that they're able
to get and which for a vinifera is about
minus 25 Celsius so if you have
temperatures constantly dropping below
that you're not going to be able to
cultivate vanilla grape vines which is
where the ones we get most of our wine
from so you might say it responds to
temperatures so why can't we predict
this and well we can in a way there was
a model that was developed in in
Washington State using field data and it
works very well for them but when we use
this model to predict our cold hardiness
it doesn't do a very good job so in in
green you see our data points of or
measured cold hardiness and in an orange
you see what the model predicted so
really what we see is that there's an
over prediction of hardiness in the
acclimation face and an over prediction
of hardiness in the d acclimation phase
and so really the acclamation face for
us is not that much of a problem but
when we look at the d acclimation here
in the in the Northeast or coldest
temperatures of the year are really in
the and the last portion of the winter
so if we have warm temperatures mid
winter and they start losing their
hardiness it's very concerning that the
model doesn't predict that for us
because of this shift and when the
coldest temperatures of the year are
here sorry the
darkus callers are later in the in the
winter and so we decided to just test
different temperatures to see how they
acclimated and just fix the rates that
they were given for each one of the
temperatures and it sounded like a very
simple idea so we took buds from from
the field and we made these single node
cuttings and we exposed them to
different temperatures two four seven
eleven and twenty-two Celsius and we
really expected them to gain hardiness
at least in the two four seven but the
model actually predicts that at eleven
it's still gaining hardness at twenty
two we didn't expect them to gain
anything when we looked at the data for
five weeks they did not gain any
hardiness in those chambers but when we
looked at the field they were at the
same time they were gaining hardiness
and so we went to see why this was
happening looking at the field
temperatures yes no they were not rooted
cuttings they're just the the buds and
single node cuttings without a reach
temperatures for five weeks yep mm-hmm
yes so when we look at the temperatures
in the field we see this and comparing
to the temperatures that we had in our
growth chambers you'll see that the blue
line which is two Celsius is really
close to the minimum temperatures that
these buds were experiencing out in the
field except for it really the later
portion here of that period and it
didn't so it didn't really make any
sense that at least in the two they
should be gaining some hardiness if we
look at the average stamp the daily
average temperature instead of the
hourly data you'll see that really for
most of the period it is above that two
Celsius and the average for the whole
period is actually around seven so we
really wanted we really expected them to
gain hardiness but there was something
to learn about this that even though
they were they were touching that two
degrees line it was going it was cycling
there was some temperature
amplitude going on and so really what I
did was I I try to search things related
to how temperature cycling affected
plants and I came across an entomology
paper that said the title was something
like Effects of neglecting temperature
amplitude in in insects and even though
the results were not relevant to this I
like the title that was the effects of
neglecting and this is exactly what we
were doing we were neglecting the
temperature amplitude that they
experienced in the field and just going
with constant temperatures so when we we
decided to expose that expose them to a
cycling chamber so we took buds from to
seven and 11 degrees Celsius and we
moved them into a chamber that was
cycling from 1.5 Celsius up to 12.5 so
that the average temperature was still
seven Celsius but they were they were
going very close to what the two was and
a little bit above what eleven was when
we looked at at these buds that were now
experiencing cycling temperatures we saw
that after we moved them into the
cycling they gained hardiness so really
they even in the two Celsius which was
essentially only experiencing
temperatures higher than what it had
seen before they did gain hardiness in
that cycling chamber so we came up with
a term that took into account daily
variations in temperature which is a
Sigma T is what we called that would
perhaps fix or model there we also did
I'm not going to show much of this but
we did do RNA seek with these buds and
we see a cytoskeleton reorganization is
up regulated and the buds that gain
hardiness and actually ABA was down
regulated which is something that is a
little bit counterintuitive but we have
a hypothesis about it and I won't have
time to talk about it but if you're
curious we can talk later and just
showing some results from this was last
year so this was two years ago so last
year we decided to
try different temperature amplitudes so
you'll see here that if you have the
bugs at 7-7 plus and minus three Celsius
all going from four to ten and seven
plus and minus five so going from two
all the way up to twelve you'll see that
when you have a range that is smaller it
doesn't it doesn't make the buds gain
hardiness so comparing the blue and the
orange line but when you when you give
it that nice ten degrees range the
temperature variation you actually have
I just realized that every time I was
pointing it was it wasn't actually
pointing so here the seven plus and
minus five was really where we were
seeing acclimation happening this is to
show some other data with two and two
plus and minus five you'll see that with
a two plus and minus five it is gaining
a lot more hardiness so the average
temperature here is still two Celsius
but it's gaining a lot more hardiness so
there is information there that we have
to adapt into the model so once we take
this Sigma T and we we plug it into the
model we are able to fix the earlier
portion of it if we use it for the whole
thing it doesn't work anymore so we have
this idea that there's different
responses in one phase and in the other
that we have to look at so looking at
the acclamation the same type of thing
we take buds from the field and we cut
them into single node cuttings and we
put them in growth chambers at different
temperature to see how they are
responding to to temperature this we did
at multiple times during the year so
when they had different chill
accumulations and you'll see here the
close that the closed dots are at the
lowest chill accumulation so both at 10
and at 22 degrees C they they have a
very negligible rate of D acclamation so
they're losing hardiness very slowly at
that point once you give more chilling
so the open dots 800 hours you'll see
that they start losing hardness slightly
faster and
when you give them 1,600 hours of
chilling that rate is much much faster
and you'll see that it's not a it's not
really a matter of where they are in
their in their initial LT because these
two time points they were at about the
same initial LTE but the rates are very
different and so if we look at how these
buds are responding
if essentially is if you take them from
the field at different points in time
they are losing their hardness faster
and faster and so when we look at how
this relationship is regardless of the
temperature so we're normalizing by
temperature and seeing from a percentage
percentage-wise how this what is
happening there we see this logistic
curve in the rates of D acclimation so a
very low chilling you have a very low
rate of D acclimation compared to when
you actually have accumulated chill here
that we called a hundred percent of the
rate of response and we call this a
potential D acclimation potential
because it's increasing over time until
you get to a hundred percent and then
your rate is not changing anymore so
going back there we see that this is
increasing and it's a logistic increase
and we created this analogy for how how
the response happens that is you have
your chillage emulation and imagine that
these buds are airplanes and so when
they have very little chill accumulation
there they're taking off so they're very
slow and then when as they're gaining
altitude they are increasing the speed
until they reach a cruising speed when
it's their maximum chilling but this
really depends on what temperature they
are experiencing and are they
experiencing temperatures like this in
the field so if you look at their
responses to temperature as as you add a
point in in your chill accumulation
you'll see that lower temperatures low
temperatures the acclimate
lower than higher temperatures so
essentially you have different rates of
D acclamation so basically you have
different types of airplanes when you
have when you're looking at different
temperatures and all of them are going
to respond in the same way to chillin if
you are taking off
you are slow regardless of what airplane
you are as you start gaining hype you're
increasing your speed and then the
faster airplane is going to be much
faster in the end but they were at very
similar speeds in the beginning so there
you go full speed depends on the
airplane which means that your rate of
the acclamation depends on the
temperature that you're experiencing now
when we look at these responses to
temperature you'll see that it appears
to be that you could fit a linear rate
in here but it would not give us the
full information that we want so if we
if we look at this process and think
about it as a biological process and we
do an Arrhenius plot which is this in
the right you'll see that there's a
discontinuity in the process so it's not
all an exponential response like it is
in the lower temperatures the
temperatures here are flip by the way
and so we really have to explore this
process creating different responses for
low and for high temperatures so what we
came up with is that the low
temperatures have an exponential
response and the higher temperatures
have a logarithmic response and combined
with the logistic response for the
potential for the acclamation so really
what we're seeing here is that you have
you have at the highest chill
accumulation you have the highest
potential rate of the acclamation over
there and as you decrease your chilling
accumulation you still have a similar
curve or a similar response but it's a
it's a lower rate at a lower
at a lower rate and then when you get to
the very low chill accumulations here
you'll see that the the rate at 22 is
very it's negligible compared to what it
is you're losing 0.1 degrees per day
whereas at full chilling you're up in
the 2 degrees C per day range so we take
this and we go back to our field cold
hardiness and what we're putting in
there is a we're integrating the effects
of the rate of the acclimation and the
chill accumulation throughout the whole
winter and when we plug it into the
model corrected with the with the lt's
there we see that we have we have fixed
this model and now we can predict much
better where the cold hardiness is so
this this was one of the objectives that
we had to fix this model so I think
we're very close to getting there and
having something that is useful for the
farmers but there's some more
exploration that we can get from from
this data so if we look at this these
are three different genotypes we're
looking at right Perea Riesling and
Cabernet Sauvignon and so in the in the
bottom you have the LTE so the hardiness
being lost over time here and on top we
have the phenology so early bud
technology or bud break in which the
three is what we consider to be bud
break and so you see that these these
genotypes they are staggered so the ripe
area loses its hardiness much faster
than the other and it also breaks bud
faster than the other genotypes and then
you have Riesling and capsule but if we
take the what we learned about the rates
of the acclamation and we know the ripe
area is faster than reasoning which is
also faster than Katsav we can fix them
based on thermal time calculation for
this and so we see that we can actually
put all of them together based on this
thermal time it's just the fact that
they perceive temperatures differently
across these genotypes
but when we look at their other
phenology you see that reasoning and
capsule are now together so they are
breaking but at the same time with the
same thermal time but ripe area is still
a breaking bud faster which might not
make much sense now but I'll show you
some data later on that explains this so
I I mentioned and the dormancy and eco
dormancy and I showed you how the rates
of G acclamation change in that period
and that this is really is a
quantitative trait so you have a
continue it's a continuous response in
there but typically what we do is blood
brake assays to measure the the switch
from end or dormancy to eco dormancy and
the way that that's done is we take buds
from the field and we put them into a
into a chamber usually at 4 C so that
they four Celsius so they are
accumulating chill at a certain rate and
and then we take buds from that from
that growth chamber into 22 C and we see
how long they take to bud break and
usually the response that you see is
there's differences between insufficient
chilling and full chilling and how long
it takes for bud break to happen and how
synchronize that bud break happens and
so you can see here with insufficient
chilling that you have your very you're
not synchronized so some buds are
breaking well whereas others are not and
then when you get full chilling that bud
break happens very synchronously what
this data looks like when you look when
you put it in there in a graph is that
as you accumulate chill here is tying to
bud break from when you started your
assay at low chill accumulations it
takes a lot longer and you see that this
curve is is more it slanted so the
synchronicity of those buds breaking is
lower than as you then when you
accumulate more chilling but really
what's important here is that the time
difference from what is used for this
type of theta is the time to reach 50%
bud break if we look at those data there
in the graph
the typical exploration of this is that
we'll create a linear rate for those
buds for the time to bud break and
there's an arbitrary time that is 28
days to bud break and that's what you're
chilling accumulation is for that
specific genotype but when we do that
we're really ignoring curvature that you
can see in this data that is there and
I'll show you how that curvature is
actually similar to what we're seeing in
our rates of D acclimation the way I
actually started looking at this was
because when I looked at the bottom
portion of that curve that rate that is
in there is actually very close to the
rate of D acclimation at 4 Celsius that
we saw when we were trying to deactivate
them at that temperature and I will show
you how that affects your your time to
bud break I'll skip that so if up here
we have similar to the the grass that I
was showing you earlier we have bud
break on top and your initial LTE and
the bottom when you think those buds and
you put them into forcing conditions so
at a high temperature they you met her
there LTE there they have a normal
distribution and they're gonna lose
hardiness and imagine that you're
keeping your air there but now you're
looking at their air in the horizontal
direction so the the buds they have the
least hardiness are are getting to the
bud break part faster and the ones that
are lower are getting to the bud break
later and so if we look at the shape of
the curve that we had before it just
changes from a probability density
function into a cumulative density
function but then you you see that
imagine that you have
chill accumulation there so you have a
slower rate and you have that more
slanted curve and you're taking you're
taking more time to reach but break as
you accumulate chisel with a lot more
chill accumulated in that 4c chamber
you'll see that the rates are faster so
your bud break is happening at in a
shorter period of time so you see that
that that curve is sharper there and
when we look at the time to bud break
it's the size of the bar so when you
started the the bud break sa until when
you saw a 50% bud break and so you see
that the time to bud break is a lot
shorter well we expect however is that
instead of having this sort of behavior
that we're measuring here is that we are
losing
we are losing hardness at 4°c as you
accumulate chillin so I imagine that you
took those buds from the field very
early in the winter and they have an
accumulated and chill and so as you
start giving them chilling they actually
start responding even to those
temperatures in which they are
accumulating chill so they are gonna
start losing hardiness so instead of
measuring your time to your time to bud
break as these bars that we had
previously because you're you're
starting from a different start point
you're actually going to have a shorter
time to bud break there than what you
actually expected it to be if you have
the same initial LTE and so if you
actually try it later on and you have
already maximized your rate of the
acclimation you're still going to
perceive a shorter a shorter time to bud
break but that's not based on the on the
response of the buds to to that forcing
si but really how they are responding to
the temperature in which you're storing
them so if we take that into account
then we're able to separate this in
three different portions that you're
getting to with the bud break assays but
you're combining all of them together
one of them is your initial LT
so depending where you were in the
beginning of your of when you collected
your buds that gives you part of the
time to bud break the other portion is
the rates of the acclamation so how fast
a given genotype is that's going to give
you a piece of information and then the
last piece of information is really its
response to chilling so is it responding
to the that chilling accumulation when
is it maximized so that's the third
piece of information that you actually
combine all of those into a single data
point when you when you explore them as
the time to bud break in a linear way so
here is just showing what we expect is
happening and this data sort of works
with if you see the open dots here that
are slightly lower than the than the
closed dots those had a lower a higher
initial LTE so they are the dotted line
here and the dark dots are the are the
the dashed line so if it works with the
data we still have to make a have an
experiment where we actually track the
lt''s in the beginning of the experiment
and the time to bud breaks so we can
really make sure of what's happening
there but this is our the hypothesis
that we were working on now I'll skip
this we looked at gene expression of
buds losing hardiness and one of the
things that we saw was that the ABA
pathway was down regulated so they were
they were decreasing their ABA
production as they lost hardiness and so
we tried to use that information into
actually applying into the field so we
took again we took buds and we put them
in a growth chamber we applied ABA to
them we sprayed them with very high
rates compared to what you typically
have in field applications we use zero
ten and twenty millimolar and what we
saw is that in those that we have
aba they stopped losing hardiness where
is when you don't apply it it's still
losing hardiness and we see that also in
in the phonology you have a delayed
phonology when you apply ABA to the buds
so we see that we took that information
from or RNA seek data into applying it
in the field but all of this is just
taking that information is really
exploring that LTE data to its maximum
but there was this guy who said in 1897
he said that the direct observation of
freezing of the freezing cell is the
best means of obtaining information on
the causes of death by freezing and that
is really because we are very visual
creatures we have to see what's
happening so that was so that we really
believed so we started using x-ray
phase-contrast which is a
non-destructive method to look at how
freezing was happening within the bud so
really what the what this is is that
we're taking x-rays and we're keeping
only the portion that is very all of the
the x-rays are not deviating from from
the regular horizontal path we extend
them and we we pass them through the bud
and those x-rays will interact with the
densities with the different densities
in the bud and as they go by you'll see
that some of them are going to interact
they they chase or pass slightly and
because of that interaction you actually
have a signal in an image so you get
your get your x-rays there this is
different from what absorption x-ray is
when when you break a bone because the
the variations in density are very
slight here in the green tissue so we're
not able to use the absorption x-ray and
we're also doing this while we were
freezing the buds and I'll stand
rotating them
so we are we are doing a CT scan of buds
at the synchrotron and this is just to
show you what it looks like so this is a
this is a butt of ripe area that word
slowly slicing through it so this is
after the reconstruction that's what it
looked like you're seeing the xylem
vessels here in the stem portion and I
think you might remember I mentioned the
bud cushion you see that there's no
vascular ization here in the base of the
bud so it's not really connected to the
xylem and that's what gives it the
ability to supercool the fact that it's
separated from the king so that's what
the what the images looked like and we
can we can look at them afterwards
so also incorporated in this is we use
needle thermocouples they have a tiny
thermocouple in the tip of that needle
that measures the temperature and we're
able to stick those inside the inside
the button and this is this is what they
look like they're very tiny and this is
just comparing in the field what it
looks like so you see that the the bud
temperatures sometimes it's different
than the air temperature now I'm showing
you this video and I'm actually going to
scroll through it because you're gonna
see the the bud this is a bud of a mere
incest as it's freezing and what we see
is really an expansion of the tissue so
I'll go back and forth and you'll see
that it looks like it's it's breathing
and from there we can identify that the
base of the bud is where the where the
freezing actually starts and then it
propagates throughout the whole bud and
you see the the the top portions of the
but is only freezing much later on the
whole process of freezing actually
happens through a time span of three
minutes in this case and we were
lowering the temperature at 50 degrees
Celsius per hour so it was a very steep
rate and it was still freezing only it
was still taking three minutes for it to
fully freeze so after we reconstruct
these buds were able to see what they
look like from the inside and then
you'll see this is ripe area and you see
that the bud is really expanding there
and one thing to notice if you remember
that ripe area had a different
technology compared to the vanilla's you
see here that they six you already have
these scales separated so you're already
at a different state you're this is
stage 1 this is stage 2 and this is what
we call stage 3 and you'll see that the
inflorescences is expanding very quickly
throughout that time because this is a
non-destructive method we're able to
actually measure the freezing all these
specific buds with those needle
thermocouples and so we see that that
bud at day 0 was freezing at minus 22
Celsius then at day 6 that bud was
freezing at minus 15 Celsius and at day
13 that bud that was already very large
was freezing at about minus 8 Celsius so
you see the hardiness being lost and
we're able to actually measure from the
specific buds that we're imaging in
vanilla here looking at they 0 and day
13 so the extremes that I showed you for
a ripe area you'll see the vanilla is
still closed at day 13 even though it's
lost all of its hardiness it's still a
close bud you can see that it it's
swollen it's a little bit larger but we
don't perceive it yet as being a stage 2
so it's phenology is delayed compared to
that of ripe area and that's largely
because of the difference in growth
within those between those species
vanilla is actually expanding the base a
lot more than it's in fluorescence so
the inflorescences are so small
even and it already lost all of its
hardness as compared to in ripe area
where we're seeing that really large in
fluorescent mus is a different wild
species is very interesting in in its
structure because even at bay zero you
see that there's a lot of tissue in
there
so it's all green tissue it doesn't have
all that airspace that we were seeing
compared to the other species so here is
looking at day 0 from those 3 species
and you'll see that mu ences is really
full of green tissue there's no air
pockets in it whereas the other species
have their pockets they also have very
different sizes these are to scale these
images so it was it was interesting to
see that that was the this was the bud
that was freezing in that in the first
video so you can see the different
portions of it expanding so now we were
able to take that information to study
specific tissues of the bud and actually
learn what is happening and those
tissues that it's failing for it's cold
hardiness so some of the conclusions
that we take from from the data that I
showed you is that acclamation and D
acclamation portions they respond
differently to the temperature stimulus
and really is the acclamation is
responding both to the absolute
temperature that the buds are
experiencing and the amplitude of that
temperature whereas the the D
acclamation is really only responding to
the through the absolute temperature but
that's not a linear response as
typically is used with those data the
dormancy transition is a quantitative
trait and this is very helpful for us
because now we can explore it better and
we can separate those three traits that
are associated with this with the
dormancy studies and so there's
information that we get from the bud
break data that perhaps we won't
necessarily see if we just use the rates
of the acclamation so perhaps combining
those two is a necessary step that we
need to really
and what is the dormancy and how is
chilling being accumulated in the buds
and here the acclamation is partially
growth and I put that partially in there
because we see especially in the field
we see react LeMay ssin so if they
experience warm temperatures and then
the temperature lowers again they'll
gain a little bit of hardiness so it is
a slightly reversible process and if it
was only growth we know that the
definition of growth tells us that it is
an irreversible process so the loss of
hardiness can't be only growth because
otherwise it wouldn't we wouldn't see
that reversibility and potentially
because it is partially growth is that
when we use ABA we're we're able to stop
that growth from happening and then we
prevent that loss of hardiness so this
is where the application in the field is
we might be able to in the future
apply ABA and prevent damage in the
later winter if they if they don't lose
their hardiness so with that I want to
thank all the people that helped me with
with collecting data especially dr.
thorn from my committee and Ken at the
chess who is the one that pushed me into
getting those images and really special
thanks for for the lab group the rice
group and Jason the Jason was the one
who said every time I came up with a
good idea with a not a good idea with an
idea he would say yeah we should try
that and then Bruce was the one who put
the steps on the break and said about
this time last year he was like maybe
you shouldn't be sitting on this
mountain of data as you should start
working on and towards finishing your
degree
thanks for them for working together
into something that I guess work and
thank you for listening to me and I can
take questions that you may have
okay thank you when economically
feasible do you think it would be to
spray ABA on on an orchard alright I
guess Geneva can usually cure the
question but the question was how
practical and feasible would it be to
apply ABA through the orchard so that's
a very good question it is a very
expensive product right now and the
concentrations that we were using were
very high
but if you think about the amount of
wood that is going to be left in your
vineyard and that is very small the
volume that you would be applying if it
was directed would be very very small of
course with that comes a lot of a lot of
problems like the ABA is actually a
photosensitive molecule the s ABA that
is used and so I'm trying it right now
in the field to see if it actually works
with just spraying them because it just
it might get degraded before it can have
an effect on the buds so I think now
that we understand that ABA can have an
effect and that we can use it then we
start exploring how applicable it is to
use it in the field but it's coming to a
we have an idea of how to mitigate the
damage not just know that damage happen
yes I exchange an email about the micro
molecular mechanisms of cold acclamation
and these late embryo Genesis proteins
that that are intrinsically disordered
how they might act us as credit
protectants if you give it any more
thought to that or in general it's the
molecular mechanisms by which you're
becoming cold-hearty okay so the
question is if I had if I have given any
thought to the molecular mechanisms of
acclamation I as I mentioned before we
have a data set for
RNA seek on what has changed in what
genes are being differentially expressed
I haven't really analyzed it fully to
see what's happening as I I mentioned
there's a reorganization of the
cytoskeleton which is something that
that happens that has been seen in other
plants and there's also a low
temperature correlated protein that I
remember EC that is a gibberellin
related we also plant hormones playing a
role but from from the cytoskeleton side
it's interesting that they are changing
their structure the structures of the
cells from the physical standpoint
because they are able to resist a very
low temperature and maintaining that
water in the liquid state in an
interface with ice they are actually
lowering their water potential to a very
negative state so they're withstanding -
250 bars or something close to that in
those cells which is something that
doesn't typically happen except for in
the winter so you see that there's a
need for structural reconfiguration of
the cells but yet more more than that
now yeah we haven't seen and we actually
expect that a lot of it is a response to
dehydration because those buds actually
lose water in a way throughout the
earlier portions of the winter interest
we look to see how many of the operate
up regulated proteins or the structure
of the proteins one more what did you
say to Bruce so the question is now with
this information how do we apply this
into a breeding program I think one of
the the best pieces of him from
that we can take from this is that split
from the bud break a say that we're
usually looking for things that require
more chilling so that they break but
later and they're not damaged by laya by
late Frost's and really we can now split
it into what has the lowest LTE what has
a low D acclamation rate and what has a
higher chilling requirement so we can
really maximize that whole process just
to have the the plants coming out later
in the in the spring so that they don't
suffer any damage from late late for us
and really late winter dips and
temperature after they have they would
expect to have the act muted so I think
really what I gave him what I expected
to give him were markers what I gave him
was now a phenotype so that he can go
after the markers thank you so much
thank you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu